tech companies respect your consumer
commission entities good morning ladies
and gentlemen this is a follow up to the
information which we already shared with
you before summer I came here to inform
you about the latest steps in our joint
effort together with the network of
consumer protection authorities just to
ensure treatment for consumers in the EU
in online world the network of consumer
protection authorities which has their
acronym CPC so just if I use it for you
to understand you know that we have been
always saying that the you consumers
have must have guaranteed the same
rights beat in selling and purchasing
offline and online we didn't come with a
specific legislation for online selling
but we always said that offline aru's
must apply also for the online world so
this is what we are now doing this
Airbnb and Facebook well we still see
some gaps in their contracts which they
use for providing their services to EU
consumers which is the core of our
debate so as you know I wanted a B&B and
Facebook to change the terms and
conditions and so I now have some
preliminary results following our call
in July our B&B informed us that it
accepted to improve transparency of
prices so the consumers can know upfront
about the final price or additional
costs like cleaning fees or local taxes
ENB will also make changes to terms and
conditions for instance it will be clear
that consumers can use all the legal
remedies available and
particular their right to see you a host
in case of personal harm or other
damages if you remember these were our
two main troubles which we which we saw
in their contracts uncertainty in the
price and the situation when in fact
their contract asked the consumers to
give up their rights which must be
guaranteed by the law so I had a meeting
with the representatives of Airbnb they
promised to me but also to the CPC to
the representatives of the consumer
protection network that they will make
the necessary changes by the end of the
18th of October and I asked them if the
people who will buy the trips and
services before Christmas can already
enjoy better contract and they said yes
however majority of the contracts are
concluded after January so this gave me
a chance also to see a little bit of the
behavior of the consumers anyway the
changes should be fully functional by
the end of this year I also had a
constructive meeting with Facebook and
as you know the Cambridge analytical
which is connected case which is
connected to his facebook services was a
stark reminder that not many people have
clarity on how Facebook uses personal
data of its users and how it works with
third parties like apps games or quiz
creators not many people know that
Facebook has made available their data
to third parties or that for instance it
holds full copyright about any picture
or content you put on it even after you
delete your account and as you may know
I don't have an account but I spoke to
many people that have and many of those
were new things for them and they were
very surprised so we want Facebook to be
absolutely clear to its users about how
the service operates and makes money
Facebook has almost 380 million users in
Europe and I expect Facebook to take
more responsibility for them and I have
no illusion I'm not naive to imagine
that all the people will read the
contracts but I expect many of them to
do so and I expect also Facebook to be
honest with those that go and try to
understand all the consequences of using
their services again on the timing
I appreciate Facebook willingness to
work with us and consume authorities to
solve all their issues also by December
this year so by the 18th of October they
should make the changes so that they can
continue the double check with the CPC
authorities whether this is what we
wanted and by December it should be done
I will not reveal that all right that I
am becoming rather impatient because we
have been in dialogue with Facebook
almost two years and I really want to
see not a progress it's not enough for
me I want to see the results and I want
to see the results which will be
projected in the conditions for the
European consumers let me finalise that
I have a very big respect for work of
the national consumer or thirties this
case which I have been describing to you
is led by the French consumer authority
which is reading this action we are on
the same page
with our colleagues from CPC and from
the French authority
and we see that this is a very useful
attract which needs stronger
coordinating powers which we already
gave them by the new legislation but we
also needed to have unified sanctions
and this is it has been proposed in the
new deal for consumers which the
Commission adopted in April and which is
the package which should improve the
enforcement of consumers rights in a
very big scope and I do hope that the
European Parliament and the member
states will adopt the legislation or the
opposition quickly so that we have this
done as soon as possible in spring next
year thank you very much thank you very
much commissioner I'm sure you found our
press material which we have already
circulated and put online we'll take a
few questions now I have to say
unfortunately only if you will focus on
first on the topic we just discussed
because the Commissioner will have to
catch a plane very soon and run to the
airport so let's start with you Jennifer
can you maybe speak through to Mike the
Guardian thank you on there on Facebook
what what steps would the Commission
take around October if Facebook has
still not complied in a way that you
deemed satisfactory what sanctions might
Facebook face either from the Commission
or from the national authorities
Facebook and face the sanctions from the
national authorities which work under
the CPC network and they will look into
the possible sanctioning after the new
year in case they do not see the
sufficient or no progress or in other
words in case they don't see the things
agreed done in practice so at this
moment the national authorities can
apply the sanctions which are now in in
the legislation and the sanctions differ
from state to state but they will apply
them and after the coordinated action
it's not a photo commission to add the
sanction well in fact this was the part
of our conclusions from my meeting two
days ago that if we do not see the
progress those sanctions will have to
come this is quite clear everything also
to Facebook because I I was quite clear
that we cannot negotiate forever I need
to see the result I just want to ask
about our B&B they are supposed to start
implementing changes on in October right
by the end of the year by the end yes
yes I asked them to give it as a
Christmas present for people before
Christmas okay but they are supposed to
start in October they are supposed to
make all the changes okay there are
still things to be done we discussed the
complexity of announcing the final price
because some of the parts of the price
are changing targets
but they know what we want we know what
they can do and we expect them to do it
by October
so after between October and the end of
the year there might be some some more
clarification but not much the main
thing is to to happen now before the end
of our 18th of October thank you yes so
just a quick question about yesterday
College Commissioner because sorry
listen America fight - what France Lee
Mirman said about situation which is not
improving by service are deteriorating
in Poland and we were discussing the
situation regarding the article 7 and
guck debate where we had reprise of the
Polish authorities and we were speaking
about the possible way forward but no
decision was made yesterday thank you so
please ask - first exam Sultan for all
your active here I'll just like to know
why exactly you don't have a Facebook
account is this because of your own
concerns about data protection or any
other political means why did I cancer
my account don't you have a Facebook
account yeah I had for a short time
Facebook account and it was the channel
of dirt it was I didn't expect such an
influx of of hatred and and I decided to
cancel the account because I realized
that there will be less hatred in Europe
after I do this but I don't want to
avoid the communication with the people
even with the critical people I have for
mail of critical comments and I reply to
those who
do not use vulgar language and so on
this is my nature I speak to everybody
who once normal honest and decent
communication okay thank you very much
are there any further questions yes
regarding the team and that's the danske
bank do you have any comment on the
situation on dance companies thank you
yes I well I will speak about it with
Danish and Finnish an Estonian Minister
of Finance on the 2nd of October because
I want to understand better where the
main errors happened but it was purely
the fault of the lack of due diligence
done by the bank itself or whether there
was also some some mistake as at the
level of the Supervisory Authority of
course this is the case which attracts a
lot of attention from my side because I
am responsible for fighting against
money laundering and this is absolutely
biggest scandal which we have now in
Europe and which is also a very very
unpleasant lesson we are now taking and
which shows the need to be much more
vigilant and much more prudent on
checking the transactions coming to
Europe from from outside after the
discussion with the ministers I will
also discuss with the representation of
the European Banking Authority because
in case we see that this is the mistake
at the level of supervision we will have
to act also on that line and it would
not be the first time I would ask the
EBA too to check the reasons and the
case you know that I already asked the
EPA to check the Pilatus bank case in
Malta and we got in a relatively short
time quite precise results which enable
us to take necessary political measures
so I expect we will do the same
thing in case we see that there might
have been also some mistake at the level
of the supervisor provision but it's a
it's shocking the scope of the scandal
is shocking and this is exactly what we
have to fight against with all
instruments we have enhance thank you
very much commissioner I don't see any
further questions thank you that closed
the press points